so first big challenge chopping to
herbes very fine let's double for the
chives cigarette here keep that board
clean stack the chives these little tail
ends discard okay how many times you
seen chefs chopped super fine and the
boards green all the flavors lost on the
board we want the flavor kept in the
herb so bunch up 3-finger rule one in
front two behind this knuckle protects
please be careful one in front their
knives either work let's use the base of
the knife and then literally just pinch
nice and find they're called run Dalls
because there's the shape of a round
cylinder now stop i clutch over the
chives and I'm not
pressurizing or bruising the chives so
as we get the maximum flavor in the dish
with the chives and I want the goodness
of the chives in the dish not on the
board and look no green on my board
super fine chives come onto the basil
open up the leaf tip the tip about 10-12
leaves maximum otherwise it starts to
bruise open up those leaves
gently roll them almost like a cigar
don't bruise the leaf clean knife hold
finger thumb free finger rule in front
and again let the knife do the work as
you see
the basil is not bruised is sliced
superfine in the Connery well this is
called a chef an art and it stays a
beautiful color if I had to push my
fingers down and look what happens the
goodness comes out and there we have the
most amazing shift nut just smell that
the fragrance inside there is incredible
and look nothing on my board clean
superfine chopped chives and a super
finely chopped basil both heards chops
without bruising it's a big difference
understood